all right breaking news earlier this
evening the house Intel committee
ranking member Devin Nunez sent a letter
to the NSA the State Department the CIA
the FBI demanding answers about Joseph's
mufe said now remember this is the
professor the academic who told George
papadopolis that the Russians
he had dirt on Clinton Hillary Clinton
remember the story and by the way George
papadopolis also will be joining us
joining us now to explain is Congressman
Devin Nunez his self congressman thank
you last minute we appreciate it the
breaking news rather than me I have the
full copy of your letter right here but
rather than me explaining it I think we
best have you did well it's great that
you you you know remembering the story
and if you recall after the Moller
report what I call the molar dossier
came out I said that we were going to
comb through it one of the first things
that we found is they used a news report
a guardian news report to claim that the
link campus was a place where Mifsud had
worked what they failed to say in that
same report is that Mifsud was actually
related to Italian intelligence services
so you can't if your molar you don't get
to just report part of what you want in
the story you have to put the entire
piece before the American people he
didn't do that so we're calling him out
this is not how investigations are
supposed to be run when you look into
Mifsud closer professor much closer you
realize that he is connected with all
kinds of intelligence agencies including
our own FBI and in that letter Shawn
you'll see there's pictures with FBI
agents at the linked campus where
Professor Mifsud teaches at so we ask
the question and I'll just get to the
I'll sum it up like this we want to know
every document that these agencies have
related to him its hood because if he is
in fact a Russian agent this would be
one of the biggest intelligence scandals
for not only the United States but also
our
allies like the Italians and the Brits
and others because if Mifsud is a
Russian agent he would know all kinds of
our intelligence agents throughout the
globe
so we asked those questions we want
those documents we're giving them a week
you said that this professor has you
know all these connections to other
Western Intel and governments and yeah
the issue about Russia which Muller
implies he was a Russian agent but it
may be much deeper as how I'm seeing
this and my question to you is do you
believe in an effort to illegally spy or
get intelligence on the American people
that it's possible that some at the top
of our intelligence chain community
under Obama Biden that they may have
outsourced things that were illegal for
them to do to Americans so that they
could have our allies do the spying for
them like let me give you an example
Great Britain or Australia or maybe
Italy I think I'm my over the target
here I think you are and and one of the
things that we point out in the letter
is we're very specific because the FBI
are I should say the Moller group claims
that Papadopoulos misled them and they
were not allowed to get to Professor
Mifsud in time in order to to interview
him this is the claims that they make
against Papadopoulos when they sentence
him to prison now what we found is we'll
wait a second if if this really happened
and if you backtrack all this and
they're basically making the claim that
Mifsud is the guy who said he had emails
or he knew of the information about the
emails being in the hands of the Russian
government if that is in fact true they
couldn't talk to Mifsud supposedly until
January February of 2017 well how do
they know to ask Papadopoulos all
through 2016 whether or not he seen the
Russian emails or whether he knows about
Russian emails
the only way that's possible is that had
to come from Mifsud
some way somehow so I think there it's
more likely that I'm gonna be a starting
center on an NBA basketball team before
Mifsud is a Russian secret Russian agent
now whom IFS is working for I don't know
but right now Sean like everything we've
had to do we have to be slow and patient
we have to get the information because
we need to see what exactly was the
relationship between Mifsud
and our FBI myths hood and our state
department that's the myth said in our
intelligence community you know by the
way I wish I thought of this myself I'm
kind of jealous
the Muller dossier which is interesting
but you specifically talk about
omissions in the Special Counsel report
and you also talked about the explain a
Papadopoulos net Mifsud now here's the
thing congressman well I'm gonna happen
to Papadopoulos and his wife on and the
story in the tale that we now know is
true even the New York Times I think
trying to get ahead of it because they
know what's coming out I don't know how
long you knew but you didn't tell me and
I wish you did but they were using you
know young pretty flirtatious woman in
this equation right out of a you know a
James Bond novel or movie to set
Papadopoulos up along with Stefan how
far along with this professor is there
anything I'm saying that's wrong and how
deep did it go well I can tell you I
said this a year ago and and I got
mocked and others got mocked I said look
I'm not interested if if the Trump
campaign was spied on that happened
that's that's fact I want to know how
many spies informants whatever you want
to call them will run into the Trump
campaign so look the New York Times
story right now says - that's up from
from one my guess is it's a lot more
than that if you listen to what Attorney
General Barr said yesterday as
sophisticated as this operation was to
have a FISA warrant on someone there had
to be a lot more involvement considering
the the type of people the level of
people that were involved
in this investigation from our own FBI
so my guess is I'm still holding to what
I said a year ago I want to know how
many spies were run into the Trump
campaign and I still don't know but
we're gonna get the answer and we're
gonna get out to the American people I
count three instances when you include
FISA but thank you for being with us
congressman please don't stop what
you're doing this is too important to
the foundational principles of the
country